storm
i don't know if you've heard but i am
scaling back the x-men a little bit i
mean um don't tell the others but your
powers fantastic controlling the weather
it's really something thank you xavier i
will only use my gifts to aid those in
need well yes always help those in need
when you can that is
what i said
of that
do you remember um last saturday i
decided to play golf you know with my
mind and i did
tell you that i was going golfing and
once we got there 45 minute drive it did
um
start to rain and it um
ruined our day a bit
okay
this saturday i'm also
going golfing and the forecast says rain
and
i don't know if anybody perhaps in the
room could help maneuver around such a
predicament are you asking me to change
the weather so you can recreate no no
i'm just saying if i'm not golfing on
saturday i will have a lot more free
time to
see if you deserve to remain in the
group
i cannot believe that you are
blackmailing me yes maybe i'm
blackmailing you a little bit if you're
not going to help me golf then what are
you good for fighting evil you know
what's evil is a wasted saturday at a
country club with a six-month waiting
list do you understand how many strings
i have to pull to get a game
if i lose to scott again i'm probably
going to kill everyone just everyone
with my mind and do you want that fine
i'll make it clear on saturday and
sunday
and sunday sunday i'm going to the park
and there's a very loyal family of small
small ducklings that has become quite
engaged with me ducklings i think
they're beginning to accept me as one of
their own also
it hasn't yet been cold enough at night
to use my new hot tub it also hasn't
been quite hot enough during the day to
use my slip n slide also i'm going to
new england if we're not busy this week
i'd love to see the leaves change i know
it's summer but could you drastically
change the ecosystem that i might watch
them die i quit
you can't quit you're fired fine
enjoy your weekend
it looks like rain
bunch of bullsh
scott
yes we can't golf this saturday that is
not a forfeit
really
what about now
oh perfect
perfect
telekinesis for the wind